hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled standardized and
reproducible solutions for flow
cytometry analytics this webinar is part
of the fifth annual drug discovery and
development virtual conference and i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and sponsored by miltoni
biotek for more information about our
sponsor please visit them at
www.milneybio
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker
emily bozek a product manager at miltoni
biotech for a complete biography of our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top left of the screen emily
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
all right hello everyone uh thank you so
much for joining us today my name is
emily bozek and i work as a product
manager for miltoni biotech
today we'll be going through a
presentation on standardized and
reproducible solutions for flow
cytometry analytics
so a little bit of uh fast facts uh some
information about milton biotech
uh so we were founded in 1989 in germany
uh right now we have more than 3 500
employees worldwide
uh across a number of different
countries
and currently have
uh over uh 46 000 close to 50 000
different scientific references uh we
sell and provide
uh greater than
17 000 different products and notably um
we're very you know proud to share this
that we have served and treated
uh around six thousand different
patients worldwide using our
technologies
so um
really have been involved heavily in the
cell therapy immunotherapy space
so um our
mission is really to advance scientific
research and medicine by providing
solutions
uh for curative cell and gene therapy as
well as biomedical research so we are
heavily involved um in the
fields of cancer immunotherapy
neuroscience stem cell
cardiovascular
studies and we
translate that typically into clinical
therapies
in graft engineering regenerative
medicine and immunotherapy
more specifically today i'll be focusing
on immunotherapy and flow cytometry
analytics for that
group of pre-clinical and clinical
research
so we do provide um bench top to bedside
uh products across a you know vast array
of different types of portfolios
so you know anything from sample
preparation using tissues to cell
isolation cell activation cell culture
products
plenty of cell analysis products which i
will be focusing a lot on today with our
max quant flow analyzers and antibodies
but we also have a large imaging
portfolio for high content
imaging and light sheet microscopy
and all these products can help to
translate
um
that you know basic bench top research
to the bedside for clinical applications
in areas like graft engineering
and immunotherapy which i'll be focusing
more on today
so at miltoni we have uh three decades
of experience in cell therapy and we're
very much dedicated to
expanding our reach to new patients and
innovating on those solutions that we
provide
to benefit researchers who are creating
those next-gen therapies especially for
new clinical applications as well
so on this front our key focus one of
our key focuses is immunotherapy and we
have decades of experience in
immuno-oncology
the clinimax platform is really one of
the
premier platforms in immunotherapy
including the clinimax prodigy for cell
therapies it's an automated integrative
platform for t-cell engineering and also
has been used in other application areas
as well
um the platform also has the ability to
do customized applications if uh
you know that is what the
group determines they need
so a big focus on what i will be talking
about today in relation to flow
cytometry analytics is for car t cell
studies
so as of uh just uh in february of 2022
there are over 760 different studies
around the world that are either active
enrolling or recruiting just for car t
cell studies so it's a
massively growing field and you know
something that the the whole world is
working on together
so um
what is what is car t so a lot of a lot
of people know this but uh car stands
for chimeric antigen receptor t-cell
therapy and it's really achieved
significant success in the treatment of
hematological malignancies
so in recent years uh fast-growing car
t-cell clinical trials have really been
growing and have really explored their
potential
for a number of different application
scenarios so as you can see on this
graph
across a number of countries the
the number of studies are growing and
increasing year by year
uh in the last uh you know decade or so
of this being available
one of the questions though that we get
pretty often at miltoni is you know you
have this you know great automated
platform to produce
autologous self products so why is the
cost of manufacturing still so high
given that you have that automation
um it's a very good question and it's
it's true uh it's still extremely
expensive to produce one lot of an
autologous t-cell therapy
so where is that coming from
looking at this particular study
labor far and away
compared to you know just like capital
equipment
materials consumables you know other
other types of costs labor is you know
far and away the
highest cost in generating a cell
therapy for the patient
um
you know there's of course a whole suite
of analytical processes that come into
that labor component
for uh
you know autologous cell therapy uh
production and this includes that uh
flow cytometry analytics so today i'm
going to get
a little bit more into you know ways
that we can
streamline and make this a lot more cost
effective faster easier
for that
analytics qualification process
so it's also pretty you know important
when we're thinking about that
qualification characterization process
uh for cell therapies
using flow uh it's it's important to
understand the critical path
uh to the clinical space um in both the
upstream of you know submitting an ind
but also you know past that so um
as you're you know working upstream of
submitting an ind there are a number of
you know major hurdles
uh to overcome during each of these
different steps of development tech
transfer and then getting to the gmp
space
so you know if there are very manual or
difficult steps it really can be a
bottleneck to get all the way to an ind
and without appropriate analytical
methods it can really be difficult
to have you know those early stage
feasibility
experiments or studies
but once you achieve those you can you
can scale up and do you know part of the
the track the tech transfer at that
point
but the
you know that that particular process of
transfer and engineering can be a
bottleneck and often flow
cytometry is you know a critical part of
of that tech transfer
the um the transfer to gmp as well
requires specific methods to be
developed for for a smooth transition
and if you're lacking those methods at
that state this can really delay
your process qualification uh your in
use and shipping stability studies as
well
and you need to get to those long-term
stability studies in order to you know
submit
uh your ind properly so today i'll
really be focusing on some of those
methods to mitigate delays and
accelerate the time to ind and to market
by showcasing some solutions that
miltoni has
specifically in the flow cytometry
analytics space
so
it's important to understand the the
relevance of reproducibility so there's
a study done back in 2015 that looked at
you know all the different components of
reproducible and irr reproducible
research and i'll showcase that a little
bit later
when it comes to reagents um but you
know it's important to keep in mind that
your
ear reproducibility
of results can cause
uh tremendous you know economic damage
when it comes to to companies and you
know just time
lost um which really leads to you know
longer drug development timelines
and um you know just more of a headache
for for everyone involved in this uh
particular area of research
so
you know the types of categories for
pre-clinical irreproducibility
um you know you have uh and this this
comes from that same study you have
things like biological reagents and
reference material the study design the
data analysis reporting and then
laboratory protocols
and what it what they found is that
actually you know over 70 percent of
that irreproducibility
uh is
can totally be uh influenced by the
experimental setup and not necessarily
the study design itself so
ton of opportunity in that space to you
know deliver on better
types of biological reagents and
reference material uh and equipment in
order to you know mitigate those types
of issues
so historically uh new cell products
have originated from academic
environments and they're developed in
basic research using you know very well
trained
uh scientists translating this though
into a commercial manufacturing
environment can be
very difficult
uh you need to do scale up of you know
very manual complex
procedures that require you know
basically humans to be perfect and
that's obviously a you know very
difficult uh goal to be met
so you know what we strive for is to
remove the need for the human operator
um
excellence
and translate that to more standardized
robust integrative processes
with automated workflows that can just
increase productivity
much more so
so really the paradigm is to you know
integrate automate and de-risk this
process
so you know when you're
moving finally from uh the gmp process
to commercial production
um you have to keep in mind at each one
of these stages you know there's really
a critical phase at which you know you
can't go back and you can't uh get rid
of those variations if you're seeing
them you know later on within this
process so if you can reduce variations
early on you're really increasing the
chance to successfully transfer
your process to the to the clinical
phase
so a little bit of what i'm going to
uh be going through today is what we
call ipc qc in cell manufacturing
and uh this is a this is a place where
flow cytometry standardization is really
key
so a little bit about the process of um
you know car t-cell infusion
uh you have a number of different stages
and i'm not really going to go into the
details here but it's important to
keep in mind that when you're doing an
autologous cell therapy
you have this apheresis to manufacturing
back to infusion stage and at each one
of these stages
you
can be using a number of different
methods including flow
to assess product composition product
sterility the process status you know
how well did your
transduction go
uh you're looking at compliancy and
timing and so all these aspects um in
ipc qc are really crucial for this whole
process those quality control steps have
to be validated and qualified and
they're also necessary in order to
um have the final product for release
back into the patient
and so you know at each one of these
steps you need to have
um you know flow analytics to assess you
know the quality of your product um
during in process and then at the final
stage of qc in order to to release that
cell therapy product back to the patient
so today um specifically for
uh car t cell studies and
understanding
uh how we can you know mitigate sources
of variation we'll be looking at five
different
sources of variation that contribute to
it in flow cytometry specifically for
cell therapy
in the immunotherapy space so
donor variability is uh the first one um
it's obviously very patient driven
pre-treatment driven and collection
driven and you know there's only so much
you can really control
um you know when it comes to donors
also going to go into a lot of depth on
reagents you know lots a lot differences
specificity sensitivity of you know
antibodies that are used in flow
we'll go into um some solutions that
melteni has
innovated on when it comes to
instrumentation of our max quants
uh innovation when it comes to
analysis and reporting uh things called
express modes that i'll get into
and then you know very briefly just on
the support we can provide when it comes
to protocols um you know when you're
working with you know non-optimized
procedures and trying to get rid of um
you know man manual handling
so the first source of variation i'll
touch on and you know really the
briefest is just on donor variability
it has a huge effect on whether or not a
cell product will have a reproducible
and
consistent performance so in that table
on uh that you're looking here you're
that we're showing is you're looking at
you know different populations of
subsets of blood cells
uh that did meet the dose criteria for a
patient or did not meet the dose
criteria for that patient so
you know
there's only so much we can do um and it
can be it can potentially be mitigated
by cell processing steps like cell
enrichment um
but you know beyond that um
you know there's not anything
particularly direct that we can do with
flow cytometry uh to improve this
going into that next source of variation
in flow cytometry analytics we're going
to look at reagents now for for a bit
so um it's estimated that the u.s
pre-clinical research spend in
categories of errors that contribute to
ear reproducibility
is extremely high you know right around
50 percent
if we look deeper into those sources of
irreproducibility you can see that a
majority you know almost
uh 40 percent is spent
the majority parameter 40
uh is spent on reagents and and
reference material
so you know no doubt you could improve
you know the training um the design of
the study
um you know an increased quality control
to to add to that uh factor but the you
know the very fact of not having good
quality you know reagents and reference
material uh could really improve um you
know society-wide the the quality of our
of our research and the spend and the
money we you know invest into it so you
know it's a huge issue um and you know
it's something us it's estimated
something that you know over 14 billion
dollars a year are wasted and could
potentially be
improved on um you know working better
in improving that quality of reagent and
reference material
so a lot of this in flow um you know not
surprisingly is due to the antibodies in
particular
so they're very much a large cause of
irreproducibility that we see in
preclinical research
uh so back in 2008 through 2012 a number
of studies were conducted specifically
to look into these causes and by 2014 to
the present day there are a number of
active groups of which miltonia is a
part
to really work on improving these levels
of non-specific and irreproducible
results due to antibodies
we've certainly made progress but you
know
as a whole there's there's always um a
ways to go and a number of ways to
improve
so what are some of the factors that can
result in irreproducible data in flow
cytometry so there are many and some of
the major categories are are listed here
and some of these probably don't come as
a surprise but you know taken all
together um it really it really lends
itself to a really complex
uh type of um you know analytics that
needs to be controlled better
so
you know with antibodies um a lot that
are out there on the market are you know
very poorly characterized they may not
have sufficient sensitivity
lots a lot uh groups of antibodies can
uh vary widely in performance um
and how they bind
there can be a lot of background noise
they may be non-specific to the target
that you're actually trying to
understand
the manufacturer may not have a lot of
information on it so you you know you as
a researcher may need to do a lot more
uh investigation on your end to to get
more data out of it
uh with you know in relation to that you
may not know what the performance of the
antibody is like so things like how does
it perform under fixation
um you know could be really useful to
know before you know buying a particular
antibody and
using it in your experiment
um
the protocols that are provided uh with
the antibodies may not often be accurate
uh for for the particular antibody that
you're going after in your panel
and then finally
um
you know there are so many other
variables that can be included um in the
manufacture of antibodies that just
require
um you know different types of controls
along the way of manufacture
so today um what we're going to you know
discuss when it comes to reagents is you
know how to how does ms miltoni help to
you know overcome these reproducibility
issues from the reproducibility crisis
that uh specifically relate to
antibodies so
at miltoni we have worked through three
different solutions when it comes to
reagents
we use advanced technology through a
re-affinity recombinant
antibody
technology we have proper validation of
those uh particular antibody reagents
and also include thorough documentation
uh for
for all of our different recombinant
antibodies uh we have the ability with
uh recombinant antibody technology to
to innovate you know by ourselves in
this flow space but we also work with
you know researchers around the world to
do uh that proper validation of those
antibodies
and then you know work with others for
for thorough documentation as well so
really you know in a way is kind of a
team effort
so at the moment uh before we get into
you know recombinant antibodies it's
important to understand that there are
you know currently three major uh groups
of antibodies that are that are used in
flow
so this chart kind of highlights uh just
general
uh high level overview of those
different ways of manufacturing
uh antibodies so polyclonal
antibodies are a mixture of
heteroheterogeneous antibodies they
often recognize several different
epitopes and you may see a stronger
signal
they're made from purifying the serum of
immunized animals but the issue with it
is that
um
there's very low lot to lock consistency
and so for that reason
it's really not the right antibody for
flow at all
so the next generation of antibody
monoclonal or hyperdoma-derived
antibodies are a much more homogeneous
group of antibodies they recognize one
epitope and so have much higher
specificity than polyclonals they're
purified from clones of immortal hybrid
cell lines and so they do have a higher
lot to lock consistency
but really still
you know aren't the aren't the best
solution out there uh when it comes to
flow
so recombinant antibodies are
genetically defined antibodies they're
defined very much on the dna level
and they recognize one epitope with the
highest amount of specificity they're
genetically engineered and produced in a
very controlled and defined expression
system unlike
monoclonal antibodies from those
hybridoma cell lines and so they really
offer that highest lot to lock
consistency
for flow cytometry analytics
so you know most researchers nowadays um
you know use monoclonal hyperdomas uh or
a combination of recombinant antibodies
and this is really
you know the way that um you know flow
has has gone you know much more
recently so
let's understand a little bit more about
the differences of
hybridoma derived antibodies versus
recombinant
derived antibodies so hybridoma clones
are generated for antibody producing b
cells and they need an immortal myeloma
cell line in order to continue to pump
out
uh antibodies so those cell lines are
generated for a long time and can
generate spontaneous mutations and
changes to the antibody due to genetic
drift
all this leads to lots lot variability
and decreased purity in the final
product
so recombinant antibodies on the other
hand
um are quite different in that they have
a very defined genetic sequence they're
programmed to express that particular
antibody product and because they're not
cultured in b cells they have a much
more
controlled culture system they don't
have the same types of contaminants that
you see in hybridoma models
so miltoni offers re-affinity technology
it's an innovative and growing portfolio
space where
we offer
the highest largest portfolio of
recombinant antibodies for flow on the
market so what is this specifically so
since 2012 uh we've been we've been
offering this and and innovating on it
so what you're seeing on the left here
is a model of the antibody where we took
advantage of genetic engineering so the
antibody variable region shown in orange
is typically derived from a hybridoma
clone that was validated on flow and so
we take that sequence and you know
engineer it into uh the recombinant form
of the antibody
so then you have you can see the
backbone in purple
uh the constant region um is an igg-1 uh
backbone so it's so it's universal
basically for every re-affinity antibody
and in part of the backbone um this
particular region uh is the fc region
which uh we have actually engineered a
mutation in it so that there wouldn't be
uh excess
fc gamma receptor binding so you'd
really have diminished
uh background signal
from you know non-specific binding more
easily
getting into the quality of re-affinity
antibodies so here's an example showing
mass spec data where the recombinant
antibody shows a much more pure uh
product in mass that compared to the
hybridoma clone so this pink star shows
uh the contaminating
light chain that you get in
monoclonal antibodies whereas
re-affinity antibodies typically do not
have this you have a much more pure
product with re-affinity antibodies
um here i'm also showing uh more
information on the fc receptor mutation
that we were talking about on the
backbone um so you're looking at um you
know immunoassay results where we
compared the binding of the reaffinity
antibody in light purple
so these light purple small bars here
versus the mouse monoclonal antibody in
dark purple
which are recognizing cd 144 of five
cellular human fc gamma receptors so you
can see a significantly lower binding of
that recombinant antibody than the
hybridoma to those fc gamma receptors
so why would we even really care about
this at this aspect of antibody reagents
so this is just one example of some
customer data but it illustrates it
pretty well
so the issue is really background
staining um
the area in red that you're seeing right
here shows non-specific binding from
that hybridoma clone
um the other hybridoma clone shown for
example doesn't have you know that
necessarily
uh that that same uh level of background
stating without the fc block and you can
see for reaffinity you don't even need
the fc block and you get much less
background staining and so even with an
fc block with that hybridoma clone
you're still getting you know a fair
amount of background staining
whereas the reaffinity clone performs
you know essentially the exact same
uh whether or not you have that fc block
so you know really uh makes a difference
when it comes to the quality of the data
that you're getting out um from a from a
recombinant antibody during flow
one of the other uh major advantages for
common antibodies is that universal
isotype control
so you saw
that the recombinant antibody backbone
contains that same igg-1
across all recombinant antibodies so the
benefits of this is that you know many
different hybrid trauma antibodies
within you know just a single panel
could easily have tons of different
types of backbones less leading to
potentially you know much more complex
experimental planning and inventory
management where you really only need
one
type of you know isotype control for
your panel if you're just using
recombinant antibodies so really making
um
you know a much simpler experiment and
you know inventory management a lot a
lot easier for yourself
so
i also wanted to show you know the the
level of quality that we you know go
through for our antibody production
process uh so here's an outline of that
purification process
uh first you know we have really strict
quality control of our starting
materials for both
uh you know the antibody and the
florachrome that we've you know chosen
to do conjugation for so they're
conjugated and then um you know at that
stage we do a very thorough purification
process to get rid of unbound
fluorochromes and any excess you know
antibody components
so this really uh helps to ensure that
we have a highly pure
highly consistent product
and we do final functionality testing
which i'll get into a number of examples
here
on those primary sample on primary
samples to really ensure that the
antibody is performing accurately and
precisely as intended
these are often these functionality
tests are often done on a mix of
dissociated and processed samples to
really attempt to cover uh the different
types of samples that many researchers
use
and of course
you know these studies are always
performed with a titration
uh so you're really getting a much more
you know lots a lot consistent product
than you would uh you know from
from potentially other manufacturers who
don't go through this type of process
so here we have uh an example um and
this is just you know
now i'm getting into a bunch of
different examples of the types of tests
we do on our antibody products so here
we have an example of a bunch of
different lots of antibodies
that perform identically so we're making
sure that you know lots a lot
um
you know the staining performance is
merely you know identical between all
these different types of lots this also
just helps to ensure that our customers
don't have to perform titrations every
single time they use the you know exact
same antibody
and we also have a very easily
accessible uh cfa portion of our of our
website where you know after purchase
you can look up your respective lot and
get your c of a and more information on
that particular product
so i'm going to go a little bit into
antibody specificity testing so
antibiotic specificity is really a
critical point uh because you need you
know a highly specific antibody to
really understand
you know the level of staining and the
the type of cell product that you have
uh for your you know cartier car and k
uh product so we need to be able to
ensure that the target that we're
actually going after is actually what
the recombinant antibody is targeting so
what are we doing to ensure that that
specificity is real so we perform a
number of different uh suitable
experiments like counter staining uh to
ensure that the antibodies actually
binding to the antigen of interest
we perform a knockout of the target
protein and epitope competition assays
and for specificity we perform uh siri
knockdowns stimulation of cells
overexpression of the target protein as
well as binding of uh that antibody to
purified antigen using like a latex bead
coating so do a lot of experiments
around specificity to ensure that
quality
so i'm going to quickly go into
how we
get a little bit deeper into the
knockout protein assays so we generate
cell lines where uh we knock out the
protein of interest and compare
performance of the antibody
of the knockout to the wild type and
then look at its specificity so you can
see in the wild type cell line the
target antigen is present it's shown in
red
and in the knockout cell it's gone and
we're also doing this by flow as well
so this is just nice because you know
the benefit is you know you have less
validation um effort and can be a little
bit more uh confident on that antibody
quality
uh the second test uh that i'm
mentioning that we perform is the
epitope competition uh test the clones
we make at miltoni that are recombinant
uh start with they're qualified by the
by the word ria and then a number uh so
they may not actually you know you
you'll see that you may not actually
recognize um you know the clone that
you're used to in terms of nomenclature
so um even you know even if the epitopes
that they target are meant to target the
exact same antigen as the you know
monoclonal hybridoma antibody that
you're used to
so what we do is pre uh we perform the
epitope competition assay against
established uh
hybridoma clones to ensure specificity
so the way we do this it works like a
blocking experiment so in regular saying
that uh the antibody is is conjugated to
a fluorophore and it will show a hundred
percent signal
in a competition
or a blocking
assay we use a pure version of the
antibody with no fluorochrome to block
that epitope of interest
then we dose in
the hybridoma
you know comparable clone conjugated to
a fluorophore
and that's you know the comparison that
we're actually trying to compare the
recombinant antibody against so if it
shows a hundred percent signal it means
that there were no overlapping epitopes
now if there's a spectrum of positive to
completely negative signal it would mean
that they have you know partially
overlapping or completely overlapping
epitopes and this would be a way that
you could you know look up um you know
your hybridoma clone of interest against
um the rheas that that we provide
so you can find this information on our
website um for each of our antibodies
and you'll see it on the product page
information on you know completely
overlapping epitopes to partially to
completely different epitopes with
clones that you may be you know
already familiar with
so getting into uh one of the final
aspects of antibody quality that i'd
like to talk about is sensitivity
we want to be sure that the antibody
that we're looking at is actually
sensitive enough to meet a variety of
different applications or
many different
needs that you may have
across different types of research so
here are some of the different types of
assays we use to establish sensitivity
performance is tested in flow also
tested microscopy and sometimes in mass
cytometry as well
it's also compared to alternative
hybridoma clones that are out there on
the market and
we'll display this data on the product
page of the website
we also test it against fixation and
then show data in multi-parameter flow
cytometry for just more complete
information
so that performance comparison and flow
it's just very basic tests that we do
for common antibodies where would just
do head-to-head comparisons of you know
other provider hybridoma clones against
the rio clone and display it so that
users can find it you know very easily
on the website and see if it's something
they're interested in
all right so now um i'm going to move on
to instrumentation and some of the the
innovation that miltoni has done in the
flow analytics space to help
um you know solve things around
operational tolerances manufacturing
tolerances
and just get into a little bit more
detail on that
so uh there are a number of tools and
strategies we use to eliminate human
error
data variation
and try and deliver reproducibility in
simpler use for operators of instruments
um and this is really you know a key
uh goal of ours at miltoni so one of the
aspects that we build into our max quad
flow analyzers is called smart gain
technology so this aspect of the max
quant really allows users to have
multi-instrument harmonization
so in practice max quant instruments
with smart gains allow you to run the
exact same instrument parameters from
like a master max quant in theory at
multiple sites around the world because
of the standardized instrument settings
so the challenge uh really here for a
lot of users is getting reproducib
reproducible data you know from one site
to another or with even one site to
another instrument at the same site
so to really deliver on reproducibility
you need both an intra instrument
performance
characterization and also
inter-instrument performance
characterization
so how can we enable this so to ensure
reproducible performance over time we
need to consider that there are
we need to consider and understand that
there are intrinsic differences of each
detector in flow cytometers on each
channel and each detector on each device
specifically when looking at pmt gains
on flow cytometers
this is very much inherent just with the
design of a lot of flow cytometry
instruments and not something that you
can you know necessarily get away from
however um these uh
detection channels uh behave linearly
and so you know you can calibrate them
uh against one another and get
more consistent reproducible data so
knowing this and working uh with
calibration beads
you'd use a master max font device with
a reference and control material
with a known mfi
so to harmonize those instruments with
different intrinsic properties across
sites or even within the the same site
you can use the same instrument settings
from one device to another
so this example
uh histogram shown here
shows the reproducibility of smart gain
technology
with the same sample donor across five
different devices and the overlay really
shows the ability for us to get
consistent data and for instruments to
perform similarly
so you can think of uh smart gains kind
of like uh as a lighthouse um
and
the beads you know act like that
lighthouse that stable reference point
that can be calibrated uh against so in
calibration beads we have known
fluorescent values uh that should reach
uh you know a specific median intensity
so you know device a here needs a pmt
voltage of 400 to reach
an mfi of 600 so after daily calibration
the software and the instrument gains
are automatically adjusted this is
possible because the instruments are
calibrated to known and established mf5
values
uh device b you may need a pmt vulture
voltage of 430 in order to reach the
same mfi value
of 600. so what we've done is we've
harmonized this with smart gains with
those instrument settings that are
established after calibration you get
consistent results with the simplicity
of a universal instrument setting
so all you're really doing very simple
is you have to save the data from one
instrument transfer it to another and
then continue on in your assay
so here's just some sample data that was
generated using a master max quad with
four other max quant instruments with a
standard eight color amino phenotyping
kit along with an express mode which
i'll get into in a bit
you can see that the data generated
across
many of these different subsets
many different subsets of cell types is
giving
very similar
and really consistent reproducible
another aspect of
you know a way to mitigate uh variation
in data and flow
is our
iqoq services so we do offer
these types of services for instrument
qualification
and really allow you to uh you know
maintain that gmp standard uh so that
you can get you know official
documentation
and you know really be covered there
so now i'm going to get into
another source of variation in flow
which is analysis and reporting and so
this is you know very much a human
factor in flow
um you know where where you hear people
say you know flow is sometimes an art
but we do have a way to really make it
standardized
uh across users uh with this feature
called express modes
so um express modes uh you know allow
you to kind of get rid of some of this
sample to sample variation uh so
typically you know you would need to
um you know
change the gating when done manually
even for two different types of donors
and so you can see in this particular
example you know you're not getting even
though it's the same exact gate you know
it's going uh it's looking a little bit
differently um
when you're actually doing your gaining
strategy so express modes really allows
you to
adjust it based on
uh you know algorithms that can really
help to avoid variation caused by that
human factor so here you're seeing that
algorithm adjustment
because of two different donors
in the express mode
to express modes with a little bit more
detail now
they're an automated approach to flow
cytometry analysis
modes provide a standardized
algorithm-based data analysis to really
reduce human error
allow you to have reproducible results
and provide a standardized analysis
truly based in mathematics and allowing
you also to simplify
um you know sop-based processes you can
really think of express modes as
software modules with pre-defined
settings that allow for a much faster
and less error-prone analysis
so users uh when they're you know
operating a max quant typically
manually
you know have
have a work time of somewhere around 17
minutes a panel whereas using express
modes you can get close to 30 seconds
per fan per panel and really streamline
that that analysis process
um
so when you're
uh when you're
you know actually looking at the
reproducibility of manual data analysis
compared to express modes the variation
uh that you see and you know manual
manual handling of gating uh you know of
just individual users is really much
higher
and can be mitigated by using express
modes so you're really uh you know
eliminating that human factor when it
comes to flow gating and really um you
know that major headache that a lot of
people tend to have uh in this area
so uh there's also 21cfr part 11
enabling compliance and you can think of
this also as a module
that can be enabled to to you know um
give you compliance on max quant
instruments so it really benefits the
types of users who need that high
quality electronic record and signatures
for documentation
it also makes it much simpler for
submission to to write relevant
regulatory authority authorities
the 21cfr part 11 enabling module does
allow for an audit trail so this means
that you have times time stamped audit
trails for all data files uh it's which
is recorded at the creation modification
and storage of those files
in addition it's also a closed system
with electronic signatures so you have a
secure your user login uh with password
controlled inactivity timeouts renewals
uh and attempted sign-in failures
we also have uh advanced user enroll
management systems um
it's a a way
you know you can have this optionally uh
to connect uh your customers to
your own uh it system
and finally uh there's an electronic
record uh
with comprehensive reports that include
all the necessary information in a pdf
uh that really is forgery proof and
eliminates uh you know the concerns
there
so max quantify express modes really uh
can be as simple as press and play so
the way it looks like on our instruments
is you have um you know you're basically
just enabling the type of
um you know acquisition that you're
doing and so here analysis and then the
mode so you're choosing you know the
particular express mode which i'll get
into the different types we have in a
bit
so super easy and standardized right
here and then all you're doing is
pressing play and and walking away
so the types of um examples of express
modes that we have are you know kind of
across the board this is just one and
probably one of our you know most highly
used one called the immune cell
composition
allows you to look at the array of
different immune cell types within a
population
it's a nine color panel that has you
know automated gating and um you know
can be used with standardized reagents
that i'll mention in a bit really allows
for that plug and play approach uh to
flow analytics uh for cell therapy so
you'll get readouts like you know this
large table of statistics which includes
cell types defined population
percentages uh frequency over total of
that cell type absolute cell count which
comes automatically because we have
volumetric cell counting
and uh frequency percentage among viable
cd4 uh cd45 positive cells
so this one uh as i mentioned this
express mode the immune cell composition
is one of our uh most commonly used
modes for incoming evaluation of blood
products and you know very heavily used
in the in the cell therapy space
another uh express mode that's commonly
used in ipc qc uh is
the
transduction efficiency express mode uh
so again you'll see dot plots with the
gating strategy clearly defined um in
that output and report for
you know transduction efficiency
and you'll see the same statistics table
with populations of interest and then
this time the product release
information
is also clearly defined at the bottom
there as the viable
amount of car positive cb3 positive
cells and all this can be exported to
pdfs
and excel sheets as well
so this is just a brief look at just our
car t express mode package
you can look at things like
phenotyping persistence exhaustion
activation proliferative ability
as well as some controls and then uh
analysis of malignant b cells
uh for people who
you know are in are in that space as
well uh we do have the ability we have
other express modes that come you know
automatically with max quants and then
we also have the ability to do custom
express modes for any flow panel that
you might be interested in as well
so just a quick plug
we do have
a new product stain express which are
pre-formulated dry antibody cocktails
based in re-affinity technology
um that are really designed for ipc qc
and work perfectly hand in hand with
express modes
so you know a current workflow for um
you know doing these types of panels in
ipc qc would you know be a lot of manual
hands-on labor uh but with state express
you really have that ability to just add
your sample to a barcoded tube
um
you know maybe add your license buffer
if needed uh leave it for staining scan
it on the instrument using the express
mode and then just you know plug and
play and let it go
so
uh going back to that ipc qc process in
cartoon cell manufacturing the two
different statistics panels we currently
have immune cell composition and car t
cell transduction uh labeled as one and
two can be used at you know various
stages along
your production process for
your cell product
we also have a card detection reagent so
depending on
you know your application you can
choose one of our car detector regions
and dose it into that transduction
cocktail
to really kind of understand a little
bit better that efficiency of your
product in the manufacturing process
so uh we have antigen-based
car detection reagents as well as
uh idiot type car detection regions i
guess against the fmc 63
region of the car
and so we have a variety of products
conjugated directly to biotin or to
fluorophores directly for the ideotype
car detection agent
so overall um
you know this ipc qc car t
cell process we have you know three
major
groups of of products that really allow
you to get that standardized consistent
uh analysis so you know from uh the
software modules express modes to stain
express to our car detection reagents
who really have an optimal ipcq setup
with a robust measurement
that unified antibody backbone
and um a flexible car application
depending on you know the type of
marker that you know you might need for
your particular cell product
so very last um you know source of
variation in flow cytometry analytics is
protocols
so
we took this from the
clinical lab standards uh institute um
uh proto uh
protocols that were released um we are
able to you know help you along all the
different steps of assay development
that could cause variation so you know
understanding what your intended use is
determining um you know the type of
instrument configuration you need panel
design
and then your analysis strategy
so uh you know miltoni we have the
ability to help you uh for everything
along this way from sample processing to
sample analysis
uh your process requirements
where you know we can help you with
customized express modes um the platform
component compatibility so we can work
with you you know on on
you know the instrument platform that
you're using and then of course we have
uh service and support that can work
with you every step of the way
and also
help to iterate on application
development as well
so in summary
you know the main sources of variation
in flow cytometry analytics miltoni can
really help you mitigate them
by a number of different factors from
you know our reagents with the
re-affinity antibodies
instrumentation with smart gain
technology and iqoq
our software packages and modules with
express modes which are algorithm-based
uh data analysis as opposed to manual
and then finally uh you know we have
ways of um you know improving your
protocols with automation customization
and then application support
so um all these different concepts all
these different standardization
standardization concepts will really
assist you in mitigating those sources
of variation during uh those critical
phases of process development
where you can't go back and change so
miltoni we really you know work with
with our customers as partners to get
you to you know not have to have issues
in those critical phases of you know
development to ind
all the way through commercial
production
so thank you very much um i am you know
very grateful to labyrinths for letting
us present
and please if you have any questions uh
you know feel free to email me at emily
beau at miltoni.com
and you know i can answer the question
or can you know facilitate a
conversation with someone who
may be more of an expert so thank you
very much and you know hopefully we'll
talk soon
i want to thank you again emily for your
time today and for your important
research and before we go i want to
thank the audience for joining us today
and i'd also like to thank our sponsor
miltoni biotech for sponsoring today's
webinar questions submitted today and
during our on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
february 2024 labyrinths will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye-bye